from Good Morning football and Fox
Sports as well Peter shrier how are you
Peter don't be a GFF Rich all right we
don't want to give any uh kahura here
we're going to talk yish let's do it my
friend well I mean you know uh the
Saints G if to win last night one would
say that's means stealing you don't want
to be
a thank you Rich so uh what do you think
I mean because I'm having my fun here
Brockman the uh the Patriot uh honk and
uh hater of anybody else um thinks that
breeze is toast Breeze's toast um what
what's your two cents on this
subject well look I think the peacock
thing was fitting CU a lot of people
were tweeting out visuals of the peacock
logo yesterday the way Breeze was
playing in the first half that maybe
it's time for him to get in the booth
before uh we finished this season up the
truth of the matter is the storyline
would be so much different if Breeze
didn't save the day last night we know
that the Chargers muff things up with
the kicks and that's just going to
happen but they're down 20 to3 and
everyone on Twitter is demanding jamus
Winston and Rich Breeze went 21 of 26 uh
from the second half on and was lights
out when they needed him so again I I
thought this was really impressive from
the Saints even though everyone's going
to just point to the Chargers muffin
this game this could have been a totally
different conversation this morning if
they're sitting at two and three and
Michael Thomas hasn't played in three
weeks because he's punching out
teammates instead they're in first place
and they're headed towards the bu yeah
what's the deal with Michael Thomas cuz
Payton didn't make any commitment that
you're going to see him in a Saint's
uniform after the buy what's the scoop
with him best you can tell no and and uh
shows a lot of gumption and kind of I
was impressed with Payton's decision
that despite all the injuries and the
must-win that stuck by his guns didn't
play Thomas the story that I heard and
this comes secondhand is that in
practice now they had their helmets on
there was a punch thrown at uh Gardner
chony Gardner Johnson the second-year
corner and that it was it went beyond
the usual just competitive spirit and it
carried on and on and pton made a
decision said it's not going to not
going to happen here we're not going to
do it this year we've been through too
much as a team the last few years and
through too much over the last 4 months
having been in quarantine all of August
together in a hotel we're not going to
have people punching each other at
practice and he's put them on ice for
last week but like you said there's no
guarantee he's coming back anytime soon
injury or not and I think it's a
fascinating storyline especially if they
can win games without Michael Thomas on
the field Peter shrier here on the Rich
Eisen show um and you know feel-good
stories are just amazing in the NFL and
obviously Alex Smith is one of them uh
to see him back on the field um and just
for inspiration for uh for for Dak one
would say not just Alex Smith but also
in this division uh Teddy Bridgewater I
mean how how for real do you think the
Panthers can be we had Matt rule on
yesterday they're 3 and 0 without
Christian mcaffrey Bridgewater is
dealing in this system uh in a way that
obviously Rule and Joe Brady thought he
could what do you think about Carolina
in this Division I mean are they not the
quietest most impressive team that no
one's talking about I love that you're
even asking me about them three straight
wins without mcaffrey on the field and
their defense everyone had a major
questions because they start all these
rookies they start about five rookies
their draft this year they only drafted
defensive players seven players taken in
the draft all defensive players and the
first week the Raiders came in and lit
them up in their building and then
somehow Phil snow who is a 60-year-old
defensive coordinator this is his first
year as defensive coordinator the NFL is
finding a way to mix it up and get these
guys to play football we love the
Bridgewater story and we love the Robbie
Anderson story because of course Matt Ru
was his college coach and these guys
have this great relationship but I think
the defense is the story guys like Brian
Burns and Jeremy chin a lot of people
have not seen these Panthers wins
because let's be quite honest they're
usually in the eighth Market game from
Fox at 1:00 in the afternoon when
there's a lot bigger teams being played
guess what three straight wins and
they're doing it with good defense too
and I think that's the biggest surprise
around the league everyone thought they
were going to be able to generate points
with Brady and of course with
Bridgewater and all the weapons they had
but I don't think anyone thought they'd
be able to play some defense especially
this year and they have so they're a
team to deal with they're really
difficult to get out of and I think with
Matt rule these guys are believing
they're a young team and they're playing
for their coach do you think there's
another team that was out there that
could have had Matt Rule and Robbie
Anderson hooked up um together with a
young team with the huge upside is there
another team in the NFL that had that
opportunity Peter rich in New York and
I'll be quite honest like I've got
relationships within that Jets franchise
and a couple years ago when they were
doing the coaching search it was almost
like they they gave rule the interview
as all right let's just give Matt rule
in here because he interviewed for
Indianapolis last year and we hear great
things and they interviewed kingsberry
and Rule and they let both those guys
walk out the building and they rushed to
hire Adam gase and that's the truth of
it like kingsberry got on a private jet
after meeting with the uh brass with New
York and flew to Arizona and was the
head coach of the Cardinals by the end
of the next day what could have been who
knows Kingsbury came in there this week
and took care of business and Matt Ru is
three and2 with a very young team down
there in Carolina so now um that's I
guess my way Peter shreer of turning the
subject matter to coaching with the
Falcons blowing out their entire
building with the exception I guess of
Rich McKay and then uh we saw what
Houston did blowing out the the Dual uh
rolled Bill O'Brien who who's next I
mean is it the Jets who who might be
next here if if at all what do you think
yeah this is obviously this and covid
reports is not the fun part of the job
that I have and that we work in um but I
think all eyes are on the Jets we'll see
how far this thing goes the by we's in
November but at this point you're 0 and
five you've seen two other teams already
get a head start on the head coaching
search the issue with the Jets and this
is is not like a thing you rally around
who's the coach if you fire him that's
the thing is it Jim Bob cter is it
Dowell Loggins do you go down a Greg
Williams era now with the Jets to finish
the season I think what they really want
to see there is how darnold returns
after injury and what we can see out of
darnold because if you do have a number
one overall pick or a number two overall
pick just n the nature of the game if
you have a pick that high you have to at
least consider the quarterback position
and it's a quarterback Rich draft so if
gase gives darnold the best opportunity
to succeed well then do you really want
to can gase Midway through but I would
look at that by week and just do a
checkin but I don't think we're going to
have any action in the next couple weeks
yeah and this is the reason why I bring
it up Peter obviously you know jets are
near and dear to my heart but also you
know it's a national story because if
the Jets are do wind up with the number
one overall selection um their decision
what to do with it and relation to
darnold is a monster story certainly if
the number one overall pick is up for
grabs Allah Ricky Williams type trade
with Mike dika you know what I mean uh
even though the Jets already do have
truce first round selections over the
next two years thanks to cashing in
Jamal Adams before the season which did
nothing to help with the evaluation of
darnold which is I guess my point here
is how do the Jets not know at this
point either the kids worth it or not I
mean like we you know what I mean you
know what I mean they they know they
know the stuff of which he's made
mentally and also heart you know that
he's Aces on that front he checks every
box as a face front individual for the
franchise the question is is obviously
what what can he do on the field they
don't have the pieces around I mean this
kid Smith is a pretty good wide receiver
uh beckon is a large human being who we
know is going to protect whoever's
behind him Levon Bell's liking tweets on
Twitter that cat that that carp on the
coach I mean honestly there what's to
evaluate with darnold from what you're
hearing right now well the question is
if you have someone like a Lawrence what
gives you a better opportunity to win in
the coming years it wouldn't be a it
wouldn't be a knock on darnold if they
took Lawrence it would be okay well
we've got given this three and a half
years and now we're entering year number
four and we haven't really seen the full
potential and you could say I don't care
if it's Trevor Lawrence or it's Tom
Brady or if it's Patrick Mahomes they're
not winning with Jeff Smith and Braxton
beros at number one and number two a
wide receiver that said if Trevor
Lawrence comes up in a draft you don't
get that every generation either so I
say generation every year we go to the
generation this is a quarterback of the
generation but you know what I mean you
don't you don't hope to have the one or
two pick every so often so that's the
issue with darnold like at four years in
are you still feeling like you can still
win a Super Bowl with Sam darnold again
nothing against the kid but it might
just be time to turn the page if they
find that's the determination at the end
of this thing look this is a very tough
year for him he's been injured he's been
knocked around and quite frankly I don't
think he has the tools around him I
don't think the coaching or necessarily
the skill position players are as good
as other teams and other young
quarterbacks have but at some point do
you go down this road or do you do you
say okay let's at least just start a new
with a whole new group of people faces
both on the coaching staff and at the
quarterback position Peter shreer good
morning football of NFL Network FOX
Sports here on the Rich Eisen show let's
get to uh the AFC tonight we see the
bills and the Titans cuz uh coid tests
came back clear thank goodness so this
game is going to be played this evening
and I think the bills have the best shot
in the AFC to Dethrone the chief and I
said that before I watched the Raiders
uh perform like they did in Arrowhead
what do you say about the AFC uh do we
see the the best team tonight that wins
has the best chance to Dethrone the
Chiefs or it could be somebody else
Peter the the Nuance of this game is
interesting because we'll see how both
these teams handle what they've been
through I mean the Titans for example
have had maybe two practices over the
last 10 days and that's not certainly
anything you want but I think the bills
thinking they have a game on Sunday then
they have a game on Tuesday and I speak
to guys in that organization as of 24
hours ago they're like we're not sure
we're playing tomorrow night like this
is all adversity and it's not a tragedy
like a death or anything in the in the
facility but what it is is it is this
kind of deal where all right it's going
to be a long season we're going to deal
with bumps in the road we're a young
team how are we going to handle this so
I'm curious if the Bills pick up right
where they left off against the Raiders
where they looked awesome on the road
and Josh Norman's making plays and the
defense is stuffing the same Raiders
team that just lit up the Chiefs if
Buffalo can take care of business in
Tennessee and put up points and do all
the things that they've been doing I
think they absolutely have to be in the
conversation for the AFC Championship
game and they absolutely could be on the
same field as the Chiefs which the last
two weeks have not exactly been lighting
it up and of course there is The
Undefeated Steelers that sitting out
there as well uh my next guest after you
and hour number two is Chase Claypool
who I know you spoke about at length on
good morning football today for those uh
who may have just heard of him for the
first time because he scored four times
and they've already put in a waiver
claim for him tonight uh in their
fantasy league tell tell everybody a
little bit more about this Canadian
football player here what do you got for
me well in the NBC theme of things he
was a star at Notre Dame for like one
year but his story to get there was
really cool he put on one of those
videos on Facebook of of himself doing
plays when he was out in abbottsford
British colia bunch of teams saw the
video a recruiter from Notre Dame Came
Calling and this is a true story and
Taro last year detailed it well in one
of the games Notre Dame sends a
recruiting letter and he goes to his
coach in Canada and says is Notre Dame
good at football so that is how little
he knew about American football like is
Notre Dame good at football didn't even
know ends up going to Notre Dame has
this great year and I think he slipped
in the draft because Rich we were at the
combine he looked the part he ran the
part and everyone I spoke to was like
this kid's great great personality
brings it every day and certainly is one
of these guys you want as a face of a
franchise Steelers take them they get
them they put him in the system they
didn't even work him out they didn't
even do a pro day with him because of
the whole Corona virus situation so they
get him in the 40s and already he has
four touchdowns in a game he's the he's
the last he's the first rookie to do
that since Reggie Bush did it in his
rookie year which was great and I think
he's the first wide receiver to do it I
don't even have the guy who did it since
1979 so historic stuff but a Canadian
born player who really did not have much
familiarity with American football and
here we are five four or five years
later he's already one of the household
names on your fantasy theme right and
and I I think again the reason why 1979
became such a uh and it's interesting
the Pittsburgh is mentioned in 1979
since that that was the We Are Family
year as well I'm dating myself but um
I'm in let's go I know that's the last
time the Steelers started 4 and0 was
1979 as well so are you saying to me
that chase Claypool um by asking the
person who's recruiting him is Notre
Dame good at football means he never saw
the movie Rudy is that what is that what
that means can we glean that that he
never saw Rudy if he asked a question
like that never saw Rudy doesn't know
who Rick Meyer is didn't go with boo
cook and pick Ron Palace to win
back-to-back Heisman you got no
knowledge of any of it someone needs to
beef him up on his Notre Dame knowledge
I I I like the kid with each passing
fact I learn about him honestly great
kid I can't wait to hear the interview I
can't wait to chat with him I can't wait
to chat with him four touchdowns as a
wide receiver amazing since that hadn't
been done since 1979 huh so um okay uh
who's the best team in the NFC then
through five weeks what do you got for
me I think the Packers I know there's a
lot of Seahawks fans who are listening
and they say now wait a second just the
Packers have been complete dominance and
they've done it without Devonte Adams
the last few weeks so you know they're
on the by week not top of mind right now
but you see that smile it's not even a
smile I it's it like a it's a glint in
the eye or a smirk from Rogers and it's
like terrifying I just think he's in one
of these zones that it's he's he's just
unconscious right now he's like talking
with such Zen like Peace of Mind and
Spirit and these players are loving him
this year there's no drama the coach and
him are getting along great and the
defense is doing the job so again not
the the we're not fresh off an amazing
fourth quarter comeback that Russell
Wilson just had and certainly not some
of the fan bases that are fired up by
win from this past weekend but the
Packers to me have been wired a wire the
best team in the
NFC so you've got them right there and
then the Seahawks I mean how
great name me another team that plays
more wild edge of seat games I I I I
think they play games that's kind of
like suits Pete Carol's personality like
it you know like I'm sitting there
hopping up and down and chomping on gum
too watching every down of this they
they play games that that that fits
their coach's personality from competing
to just being wild and bouncing off the
walls it's amazing yeah you know last
year's week 17 game at the end ended up
losing actually to the 49ers I would
argue is one of the best games we've
seen in the last 5 years it's never
mentioned it was so intense to the very
last play where green law stops the guy
I think it was uh the twin who used to
play for the uh the Patriots the tight
end he tackles them stops them on the
one and it's like this is every game
this year this is what they're doing the
Seahawks find a way and that drive I
said it on Monday show I think it's the
best Drive of the season and it's going
to be the best Drive of the Season 94
yards and 2 minutes and it's the full
rough Wilson experience you get on a
fourth and 10 where everyone's
clobbering Brady last week for not just
taking the first down and trying to go
for it all and Russell Wilson throws it
30 yards on the sideline of DK maaf he
does one of those pouette plays on
second down and then of course MF drops
the pass earlier in the drive and then
gets the fourth and goal incredible
touchdown but like I just never feel
like the game is over that one was I
believe you know they were shut out 17
or 13 nothing in the first half and you
know goes to halftime and we're getting
Tony dunie and the boys and NBC and I'm
like this game's not over like we have
to watch the whole thing and of course
you watch the Lakers celebration you
flip it back over and it's 2113 they're
winning like that's just what they do
and I think you're right like he is
unbelievable right now it's going to be
him and Rogers I think wire to wire here
in this this MVP various if Josh Allen
might throw his hat in the ring Mahomes
of course but this feels like Rogers and
Wilson who have been great Rivals the
last 10 years I feel like they're on a
crash course for each other again Peter
shreer thank you for the time uh as I
was tting back and forth with you over
the weekend um or I think maybe even
during game day morning when when when I
booked you um that uh you know Aman
giving a pop to good morning football
during Thursday night saying that he
doesn't miss the show he watches it
every day it's just great to hear man I
already I always told you I'd tell it to
you and Kay and Nate and um you know
obviously uh Kyle who's on tomorrow and
he's been on every Wednesday um that uh
I always thought at some point when I
was hosting NFL Total Access from o 3 to
2011 losing all my remaining hair during
that lockout year that at some point
there would have to be another tent pole
show on the network and and then your
show was born so congrats on everything
back that's that's awesome to hear and I
will tell you that you set the bar so
high for us uh on Sundays and on the
face of our Network and we're happy to
work under that umbrella so we
appreciate it my man right back at you
Peter we'll chat soon thanks for the
call yep you got that's Peter shreer
right here on the Rich Eisen show at P
shrs at p shre to follow him hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right
here